hey this is presh talwalkar
a marshmallow has the shape of a
cylinder
it has a diameter of 5 and a height of
3.
a dessert is made with 24 marshmallows
the bottom layer consists of three rows
of four marshmallows
a top layer consists of exactly the same
arrangement marshmallows are placed on
top of the bottom layer
the dessert is completed when chocolate
is poured to exactly fill the gaps
between the marshmallows
this is a side view of the dessert
here's a top view of the dessert
chocolate exactly fills the gaps between
the marshmallows
the question is what is the volume of
chocolate
this problem was asked to grade 12
students in australia
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the main principle is that the volume of
the chocolate is equal to the area of a
cross section of chocolate times the
height of chocolate
the dessert consists of two layers of
marshmallows each which have a height of
three
the total height of the chocolate will
therefore be six
so the volume is equal to the area of a
single cross section times six
we can see the cross section from the
top view
this forms the shape of six different
gaps between the marshmallows
each of the six gaps are identical
we therefore can simplify this to say
the volume is equal to six times the
area of a single gap
multiplied by the height of six
so the volume is equal to 36 times the
area
of the single gap between four
marshmallows
what is that area
we start out by having 4 marshmallows
each marshmallow has a diameter of 5
which means each circle has a radius of
5 halves
we now draw a square that connects the
center of these four circles
the square side length consists of the
radius of two adjacent circles
the side length of the square is
therefore equal to the diameter of the
circle
so the side length is equal to five
the area between the gaps is equal to
the area of this square
minus the area of four quarter circles
so we can write this as the area of the
gap is equal to the area of the square
minus the area of four quarter circles
now four quarter circles together make
one whole circle
the area of the square is equal to s
squared and the area of the circle is
equal to pi r squared
this means the area of the square is
equal to 25 and the area of the circle
is equal to 25 pi divided by four
therefore the area of the gap is equal
to the difference between these two
areas
we can substitute this back into our
volume formula and then simplify to get
our answer that the volume is equal to
900 minus 225 pi which is approximately
193.1
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description